I don't think they live together I think
it was a very hush-hush thing the Simon
Garfunkel it was the sixties and I don't
think people wanted to a sixties are so
conservative very conservative in my
need about stuff you know everything was
all do off other than any but I'm out
about milkshake milkshakes letterman
jacket you know like combing your hair
back and stuff like that hey the 60 look
at that so she at the time they couldn't
really they had to pretend like they
were just a musical act
I think of Simon Garfunkel other than
music they're probably talking about the
mix yeah that's right dog doughnuts they
would finish a song and go home man I
just want to get out of noodles so we
could go see the Mets play home run home
run home run I hate the Yankees you know
the old money - a lot of yeah they'd a
bowl like gambling debts
yeah they were the sort of mafia band
you don't you don't like that song
bridge over troubled water do you do to
me a troubled water I'm gonna throw you
off that [ __ ] bridge and I'll put
your head right through that [ __ ]
wall you understand me yeah you
understand me mrs. Robinson was a woman
that that owed them hold them a lot of
money mrs. arroz Alana the record
laborer said can you make it Robinson
yeah just to kind of for the Midwest you
know we should wait a song called the
sounds of silence cuz all you kids yeah
and my mother and my wife's murder
everyone's talking to each other what I
wouldn't give for the silence hello
darkness my old call said hold it
listen what you just said you meatball
yeah you said sound of silence that's a
song you dummy yeah we're gonna go to
Sal's recording studio and went down the
south and they recorded it and then they
did it it's true all that is true
basically are the most they were the
most violent just the worst of all the
nationalities and this is what bill said
I have no problem with inviting
Americans
I like Italian Americans oh you like him
now now I've always liked them I've
never had a problem with them I don't
why you're throwing me under the bus
with camera I have no problem with the
good bus sir hey under the bus get your
brother out for me today
as another Simon Garfunkel song yeah
we're gonna get your brother out from
under the bus we got a great church
[Music]